si es indudable que colombia tiene una
historia de violencia que no ha cesado
por el acuerdo del país en ese contexto
persisten la presencia de grupos
irregulares en con control sobre
población y territorio que muchas
muchas personas que proceden en ciudades
condados en esta situación y han quedado
atrapadas en este marco de violencia
en ese contexto pues éste hay grupos que
imponen su propia ley y esto ha afectado
por igual a colombianos y arizona miento
de estos casos debe ser investigado y
sancionado
ahora según el estatuto de roma
stern y el exterminio comprende la
imposición intencional de condiciones de
vida que leyendo textual entre otras
el acceso a alimentos o medicinas
si vamos a hablar de privación de
alimentos y medicinas como unas medidas
del término creo que el hecho de la
salida de no voluntarias forzosas de 6
millones de venezolanos que abusan de
esta imposición intencional de
limitación de acceso a comida alimentos
ya medicinas por parte de venezuela
este nos demuestra una situación muy
diferente si todo el exterminio está
siendo producido fundamentalmente por
parte del gobierno venezuela es una
acusación este yo diría que temeraria
que nos va a tener por supuesto ningún
tipo de repercusión y con dignidad en la
corte penal internacional pero que de
todas maneras si éste vale la pena
llamar la atención sobre la necesidad de
investigar y sancionar este y todos los
casos que afectan tanto venezolanos como
colombianos señora bolívar qué
posibilidades de prosperar tendría esta
denuncia ante la corte penal
internacional es realista
no como hacía anteriormente creo que no
tiene ningún fundamento que no va a
tener ninguna posibilidad de prosperar
este
por porque como decía no se ajusta a
la definición que se establece de que
tiene que con delitos generalizados y
sistemáticos no si habiendo un crimen de
lesa humanidad por el uso masiva de
colombianos en territorio venezolano en
2015 por parte del régimen técnico de la
salud que fue perseguido en una campaña
de xenofobia que los culpaba de la
escasez y del contrabando también cuando
el gobierno venezolano
decidieron retornar a venezuela por esta
situación que impuso la pandemia en el
año pasado fueron criminalizados en
venezuela donde física el general los
llamó karma la ministra de asuntos
penitenciarios los llamó traidores y por
tormentos señalados como armas
biológicas y procesados o algunos de
ellos judicialmente juegos como
bioterroristas entonces si alguien ha
despreciado y maltratado a los miles de
venezolanos en el régimen de maduro que
inicialmente incluso negaba de existir
un fenómeno de inmigración masiva
según su experiencia y sus
investigaciones cuál es la situación de
los migrantes venezolanos en colombia
muy brevemente
como decía
muchos desconocen la situación que
atraviesa el país es
que hay grupos que controlan población y
territorial diferente en este parte de
la geografía colombiana muchos
desconocen esa situación y quedan
atrapados produciéndose muerte
sin embargo tenemos las estadísticas
oficiales señalan que ha habido entre
2017 y 2021 un total de 2 mil 558
muertes violentas de venezolanos en
colombia esta esta cantidad de muertes
no necesariamente se producen en manos
de funcionarios sino también claro que
hubo riñas de fuego etcétera sin embargo
en un periodo de menor de 3 años 31 14
mil 557 asesinatos por cuerpo de
seguridad del estado en venezuela
entonces nuevo las cifras no favorecen
al gobierno venezolano en lo que tienen
que con la protección del derecho